bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct sur public sénat pour les
questions cribles thématiques consacrées
aujourd'hui à la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
ce concours financiers de l'état aux
budgets des collectivités est en forte
baisse et c'est une situation que les
sénateurs dénoncent avec force
elie sont très sensible d'autant je vous
le rappelle qu'il représente
constitutionnellement les territoires
alors pour situer quelques chiffres à
premier après un premier coup de rabot
de 1 milliard et demi d'euros en 2014
les collectivités pour voir leurs
dotations baissé de 3 67 milliards
d'euros en 2015 et au total elles vont
subir une baisse de 11 milliards entre
2015 et 2017
rappelons que le gouvernement a promis
d' économiser 50 milliards d'euros sur
la dépense publique et donc voilà les
collectivités qui sont mises à
contribution
face au gouvernement les collectivités
annonce un possible recul de
l'investissement de 30 % pour faire face
à cette nouvelle donne
plusieurs villes ont déjà alourdi la
fiscalité
d'autres maires ont choisi le renfort de
certains projets tout de suite donc on
va prendre la direction de l'hémicycle
c'est gérard larcher qui présidait la
séance monsieur christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget à
monsieur andré vallini secrétaire d'état
chargé de la réforme territoriale et ses
questions poseront sur la réforme de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement je
vous rappelle que la séance est
retransmise en direct sur france 3 et
public que c'est d'ajouts et saluer les
deux ministres au banc du gouvernement
et nous allons commencer d'abord en
donnant la parole notre collègue andré
gattolin pour le groupe écologie je
rappelle ces deux minutes deux minutes
pour le gouvernement et une milite pour
la réplique vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre puisque j'ai l'honneur d'ouvrir
cette séance de questions
j'aimerais vous poser une question
d'ordre général portant sur le lien de
solidarité
qui unit l'ensemble de nos collectivités
territoriales et qui se concrétise par
une péréquation de leurs ressources
la récente réforme de la carte des
régions va avoir un impact direct sur la
manière d'appréhender les inégalités
territoriales
en effet en diminuant le nombre de
régions et en augmentant leur taille
mécaniquement on va transformer un
certain nombre d'inégalités qui était
jusque-là inter régionale en inégalité
intra régionales la question monsieur le
ministre est donc la suivante quelle
conséquence doit-on tirer en matière de
péréquation de ce transfert d'inégalités
un échelon subrégionale par exemple ne
devrait-on pas transférer une partie de
la dotation de péréquation régionale aux
échelons inférieurs
ne devrait-on pas également fixé des
objectifs forts aux régions en matière
de réduction de leurs disparités
territoriales
l'exemple de l'île de france qui
préfigure un peu ce que seront les
grandes régions est en effet préoccupant
alors qu'elle est la région la plus
riche de france est même une des plus
riches d'europe les inégalités ils sont
non seulement plus importante
qu'ailleurs mais les elles s'accroissent
aussi plus vite
accentuant inexorablement la ségrégation
spatiale
alors monsieur le ministre comment faire
pour que la fusion des régions
n'entraîne pas en matière d'inégalités
nos nouvelles régions sur la voie de ce
haut qu'on observe déjà en ile de france
je vous remercie bien pour me répondre
mon cher collègue parole et à andré
vallini secrétaire d'état chargé de la
réforme therion vous avez la parole
monsieur minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur la fusion de certaines régions
au 1er janvier prochain est inscrit dans
la loi du 17 janvier 2015 aura bien sûr
des conséquences sur leurs ressources
fiscales comme sur le montant de leur
dgf le gouvernement a prévu dans la loi
des dispositions relatives à la fusion
des ressources fiscales et pjl notre
projet de loi nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république et à
examiner
ici au sénat il ya quelques jours qui va
venir devant l'assemblée en deuxième
lecture à la fin du mois de juin précise
les mécanismes d'harmonisation des
tarifs et des taux de certaines de ses
recettes fiscales
aujourd'hui différent d'une région à
l'autre
les transferts de compétences
départementales aux régions ainsi que le
choix de la région comme collectivité
chargée du développement économique
nécessiteront bien sûr dans la loi de
finances à venir des dispositions
spécifiques le calcul des dotations
forfaitaires des régions est simple et
permet de rapprocher les dotations par
habitant parfois différente aujourd'hui
d'une région à l'autre sans qu'il y ait
des faits non maîtrisée je vous rappelle
que la dotation forfaitaire des régions
représente 4 milliards 600 millions
d'euros sur 4 milliards 800 millions
d'euros de dgf globale que perçoivent
les régions avec 200 millions d'euros de
péréquation il s'agit donc de réduire
les inégalités entre régions et les
mécanismes de la dotation de péréquation
ce train se traduire en 2015 à règles
inchangées par des différences
significatives entre la somme des
dotations de péréquation perçue par les
anciennes régions aujourd'hui les droits
des régions fusionner demain l'impact
pourrait être étendue par le biais des
critères de répartition utilisé pour les
autres régions car c'est une répartition
enveloppe fermée vous le savez
l'objectif du gouvernement est de
concilier la prise en compte de la
situation de chaque région au sein de
l'ensemble des régions d'une part et le
souci de ne pas déstabiliser les budgets
des régions fusionner ou non d'autre
part des simulations sont en cours et un
travail conjoint avec la r f nous
permettra de proposer les dispositions
législatives adéquates au projet de loi
de finances 2016 dispositions que vous
aurez donc l'occasion d'exprimer examiné
à l'automne prochain
ce gâteau là je vous remercie monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse et je ne
vous avez vu je n'ai pas abusé de mon
temps pour la première question donc
dans ma réplique je voudrais simplement
compléter mon propos initial
et même si cela ne concerne pas
directement la dgf j'aimerais ajouter
que la fusion des régions va également
avoir un impact sur la répartition des
fonds européens de développement
régional les fameux feder il serait
intéressant donc monsieur le ministre de
pouvoir disposer de projection à cet
égard pour savoir si le volume global
attribué à la france en sera affecté et
s'il n'y aura pas trop de régions
perdante
il reviendra ensuite aux régions de
s'assurer que la répartition des fonds
au sein de leur territoire ne
méconnaissent pas trop la répartition
antérieures chevreau merci merci mon
cher collègue la parole est maintenant
madame
marie france beaufils pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen savez la
parole sa collègue
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues depuis
quelques mois madame qui reste bonne
députée du puy-de-dôme poursuivre le
travail engagé avec jean germain
elle a déjà mené de nombreuses
consultations pour définir si possible
avec les associations d'élus et les
parlementaires les principes communs
d'une réforme de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement nous en avons discuté à
la fois au comité des finances locales
et à la commission des finances du sénat
créée en 1979 ce concours budgétaire de
l'état aux collectivités locales
constituent encore avec 40 milliards
d'euros en 2014 et 36,6 milliards en
le principal élément des dotations aux
collectivités
il a connu bien des bouleversements au
fil du temps ces transformations jouant
sur sa composition sa fonction même et
les objectifs poursuivis quand elle son
allocation conçue dès l'origine pour
remplacer des recettes fiscales
supprimées par l'état
c'est un outil de prise en compte des
dépenses de fonctionnement des
collectivités territoriales prise en
compte des manques à gagner suite au
transfert de compétences mais aussi de
péréquation de ressources pour madame
pires bonne la dgf doit conserver ses
caractères essentiels et je partage
cette vision
mais comment envisager cette réforme de
la dgf au moment où les collectivités
locales payent un lourd tribut de 12,5
milliards d'euros entre 2014 et 2017
pour répandre au dogme du traité
budgétaire européen qui considère que
cette réduction de la dépense publique
est l'outil qui nous permettra de
redresser la situation
ma question est donc simple peut-on de
manière responsable concevoir une
réforme de la dgf digne de ce nom
s'attaquant aux écarts injustifiés
confirmée par la mission
n'est-il pas temps de donner aux
collectivités les moyens de leurs
actions pour les services publics
indispensables à leur population
quelle que soit leur taille mais aussi
pour l'emploi et le développement des
investissements 1
sponsable à la vie de nos territoires
pour vous répondre la parole et à
monsieur le ministre andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice nous pensons nous que c'est
justement dans ce contexte difficile que
vous décrivez que les inégalités
inhérentes à la dotation globale de
fonctionnement doivent être corrigés les
écarts de dotation non justifiées par
des écarts objectif de richesse ou de
charges ne sont plus acceptables des
correctifs ont été apportés c'est vrai
par le législateur via la hausse de la
péréquation par exemple notamment cette
année
mais comment viser une meilleure
répartition des ressources en fonction
de la richesse des collectivités alors
même que près de la moitié des montants
de la dotation forfaitaire correspondant
départ figé et parfois depuis longtemps
des compensations historiques qui n'ont
plus de pertinence
aujourd'hui c'est dans cette optique une
première étape de la réforme de la dgr
du bloc communal a été réalisée en loi
de finances pour 2015
elle a permis d'agréger les anciens
composants de la dotation forfaitaire
pour y intégrer la contribution au
redressement des finances publiques
cette première étape a également permis
de rénover les modalités de financement
de la péréquation en faisant contribuer
toutes les collectivités dont le
potentiel fiscal est supérieure à 75% de
la moyenne
introduisant ainsi davantage d'équité de
justice et de solidarité dans le
financement de la péréquation
cela n'est pas suffisant il faut
maintenant s'atteler à la recherche
d'une meilleure répartition de la dgf en
revenir les critères et les objectifs de
cette dotation globale de fonctionnement
pour qu'elle soit plus lisible par les
élus locaux et plus juste entre les
collectivités le plus favorisé et celles
qui sont qui le sont moins
merci madame sénatrice
merci monsieur le ministre j'ai bien
entendu votre réponse monsieur le
ministre vous le savez comme moi là la
perte de ressources des collectivités
territoriales vient quand même avoir des
d'avoir des conséquences très lourdes
pour notre économie
elle vient d'être chiffré dans l'analyse
faite par la nfl à une perte de 4,3
milliards c'est donc très important et
quant aux premières réflexions même si
je participe au groupe de travail qui
réfléchissent mais ça me semble
difficile quand on a une perte aussi
importante de la masse globale
de pouvoir donner des perspectives
d'avenir aux collectivités territoriales
qui corresponde véritablement à ce qui
est nécessaire sur le terrain et je
voudrais vous dire que les premières
modifications 2015 qui ont peut-être
apporter quelques modifications n'ont
surtout pas apporté en effet de réponses
aux questions qui sont soulevées à la
fois comité des finances locales et dans
le travail qui est menée actuellement
par madame pires bonne je crois que la
question des charges en effet portés par
les collectivités territoriales et en
particulier la situation de leurs
populations qui viennent s'aggraver avec
les dernières informations concernant le
chômage sont des choses beaucoup plus
lourde et qui ont bien plus de
conséquences que quelques modifications
liées au potentiel fiscal comme on l'a
vu dans la démarche de 2015 c'est pas eu
l'impression que les écarts que l'on
avait déjà constaté avait été largement
modifié dans dans le contenu de la dgf
2015 pas de façon marquante et quand on
perd plus de 20% entre dgf dans un
certain nombre de collectivités
territoriales même assujettis à la dsu
c'est quand même compliqué merci vous
avez joué les arrêts de jeu main sur
collègues
la parole est maintenant à madame la
présidente michèle andré pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci merci monsieur le président
chemise mes chers collègues le premier
ministre a confié en effet comme notre
collègue marie france beaufils viens de
le dire à notre collègue députée
christine pires bonne et à notre
regretté collègue jean germain la
délicate mission de proposer des pistes
de réforme de la dgf notre collègue est
venu devant notre commission des
finances le 27 des derniers le 27 mai
pour nous présenter l'état de ces
travaux
quelques points de diagnostic comment
expliquer que pour les communes de 20000
à 50000 habitants
le complément de garantie est compris
entre 0 et 3 192 euros par habitant
comment justifier que 34800 trois
communes sur 36 1553 soit 95% soit
éligible à l'adsl qui est supposé être
une dotation de péréquation christine
qui heureusement n'a également présente
cinq pistes de réforme crée une dotation
universel de fonctionnement garantie à
toutes les communes renforcer le ciblage
de la péréquation dit vertical pour
mieux l'articuler avec la péréquation
horizontale créer une dgf des et pci
distinctes celle des communes créer une
dgf locale qui préserve l'autonomie des
communes et intègre il fait
intercommunale réexaminer les critères
d'éligibilité de répartition de la dgf
et leur cohérence
ces pistes devront évidemment faire
l'objet de simulations avant de devenir
de véritables préconisations jeux minis
sur un sujet aussi crucial
aucune piste de réforme ne serait être
écartée aussi les pistes proposées ne
semblent tout devoir sans exception
faire l'objet de simulations
le parlement doit pouvoir disposer comme
le gouvernement une évaluation objective
lui permettant de décider en
connaissance de cause des modalités de
la réforme qu'il souhaite mettre en
oeuvre
monsieur le ministre vous me confirmer
que l'intention du gouvernement est bien
d'aider à tirer tout le profit possible
de cette mission pires bonne germain et
de n'écarter a priori aucune des pistes
proposées
merci la parole pour vous répondez à
monsieur christian eckert secrétaire
d'état chargé du budget il avait la
parole monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président vous
dames messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
madame la présidente je vous remercie de
votre question je crois que dans devant
une complexité puisque nous avons là
affaire à un sujet complexe
chacun le reconnaît nous devons chercher
plus ce qui rassemble que ce qui
pourrait diviser
qu'est ce qui pourrait nous rassemble et
vous l'avez dit
tout d'abord la complexité
l'illisibilité l'injustice de la dgf
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui c'est
le fruit de l'histoire ce n'est pas une
réflexion politique soit des recettes
difficulté n'est pas de nature à
réconcilier nos citoyens avec l'exercice
de la la politique locale
deuxièmement des principes de l'égalité
afin de donner vous l'avez également
évoqué un socle dotation universelle qui
permet
à chaque commune d'assurer ses missions
régaliennes égalitaire ensuite des
modèles de péréquation péréquation
verticale ou pourra approfondir le sujet
et là je crois qu aussi et c'est
d'ailleurs le sénat qui a introduit le
fameux pic
je le dis d'autant plus à l'aise que
c'était une autre majorité qui avait
accepté de soutenir ce dispositif qui
aujourd'hui je crois remet plus
d'égalité dans le dispositif alors
certes il faudra des simulations je
crois que l'engagement du gouvernement
avec l'ensemble des administrations
concernées c'est de fournir le maximum
d'informations parce qu'il faut faire
des simulations mais je crois que comme
vous l'avez suggéré nous préconisons de
n'écarter aucune des pistes
aucune des pistes il y en a plusieurs
elles sont dessinées ce rapport n'est
d'ailleurs pas achevé une froid qui doit
s'achever cet été il y aura forcément un
dialogue sur une question complexe
conclure le gouvernement et je conclus
le président veut montrer son esprit
d'écouté de dialogue et d'ouverture
madame la présidente merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je vais
sans doute faire gagner un petit un
petit temps dans ce débat parce qu'en
fait je souhaitais véritablement entente
de la part du ministre du budget le fait
que nous allions prospecter toutes les
pistes dans certains espaces on entend
dire que certaines seraient a priori
écartée et je suis heureuse de penser
qu' il n'en sera rien dont acte merci
beaucoup
ce sera l'occasion pour la commission
des finances le même le président
absolument monsieur le président la
parole est à notre collègue vincent
delahaye pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants union
centriste
vous avez la parole hochart collègue
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues les
critères de répartition de la dgse sont
devenus souvent inadaptés et parfois
source d'injustice dans un contexte de
réduction drastique des dotations
ainsi la réforme annoncée de la dgf pose
pour l'instant plus de questions qu'elle
n'apporte de réponses notons que la
réduction des dotations et puis bien
plus douce avec les régions et les
départements qu'avec le bleu
communal en effet les départements et
les régions ont bénéficié de transferts
des frais de gestion auparavant qu'ils
allaient vers l'état ce dont n'a pas
bénéficié le bloc communal pourquoi donc
frapper lourdement et prioritairement
l'échelon local le plus directement
sollicité par le citoyen est dans le
mille feuille territorial le
gouvernement veut-il en priorité la
disparition des communes deuxième la
justice sur laquelle je souhaite attirer
votre attention celle du pilotage de
l'intercommunalité par la dgf
en effet on constate que selon leur
statut les intercommunalités net sont
nettement certaines des attaques
commuter sont nettement mieux lotis que
d'autres
généralement il s'agit des plus
anciennes et de celles qui sont les plus
intégrés j'ai ainsi pu observer des
écarts allant de 1 à 11 en termes de
dotation par habitant contre un écart de
1 à 2 pour les communes autant ces
écarts pouvait se comprendre au début de
l'aventuré intercommunal pour inciter
les communes à se regrouper autant
aujourd'hui avec la fin de la couverture
du territoire en intercommunalité ces
écarts ne semblent plus justifiés et la
prime à l'intégration maximale est fort
surprenante
pourquoi en effet utiliser de l'argent
public pour renforcer l'intégration
celle ci n'est intéressante que si les
communes font des économies d'échelle en
mettant en commun des services
cissé ne pas le si ce n'est pas le cas
qu'elle s'abstienne de le faire sinon
pourquoi les aider alors qu'elles
gagnent de l'argent
là encore le gouvernement veut-il
subrepticement sur le dire la
disparition des communes alors dans ce
contexte monsieur le ministre
pouvez vous me confirmer que la réforme
envisagée de la dgf n'aura pas pour but
caché la disparition progressive des
communes et que cette réforme visera
notamment à réduire les écarts de
notation par habitant pour les
intercommunalités en refusant de
favoriser l'intégration mais en incitant
à la mutualisation source d'économie
pour tous je remercie pour vous répondre
ça peut être un duo mais pour deux
minutes
la parole est à christian eckert
secrétaire d'état chargé du budget
la parole monsieur ministre merci
monsieur le président merci de votre
question ou sur sénateurs je crois que
vous posez là de réelles questions mais
poser des questions c'est parfois aussi
essayer d'y apporter des réponses
juridiques tout à l'heure j'attends les
propositions des différents groupes des
différents acteurs du terrain parce que
sur les deux sujets que principaux vous
évoquez sont évoquées plusieurs
tout d'abord la répartition de l'effort
de la diminution des dotations
c'est pas le gouvernement qui a décidé
seul de la répartition de cet effort
le conte comité des finances locales il
en est souvent question a d'abord refusé
de s'engager dans une démarche que nous
aurions souhaité plus juste en pesant un
peu plus sur ceux qui en avaient le plus
les moyens et pour prendre un seul
exemple vous savez que la répartition
entre les communes et les
intercommunalités sur le prenaient au
prorata des recettes réelles de
fonctionnement était de 77% du côté des
communes et de 23%
du côté des intercommunalités mais le
cfl a décidé de prendre pour 70% les
communes et pour vos trente pensant les
intercommunalités ce qui a pour effet
chacun peut le constater de peser plus
aujourd'hui dans l'effort sur les
intercommunalités
ce qui me semble pas forcément juste au
moment nous souhaitons la renforcer
deuxième exemple vous dites la place la
mutualisation dans les intercommunalités
le gouvernement y est favorable confirme
renforcer la mutualisation ce n'est pas
la disparition des communes je réponds
clairement votre question il n'ya pas
d'attention cacher encore moins affiché
bien entendu de voir la disposer de la
disparition des communes il y a une
démarche je crois la mouvement de
décentralisation qui se poursuit qui
s'amplifie qui permet de donner plus
d'autonomie au niveau des territoires
nous y reviendrons certainement cette
proposition qui n'est qu'une proposition
d' une territorialisation du mode de
calcul des dotations à la faune interco
et aux communes
monsieur le ministre monsieur de là et
mon cher collègue
oui monsieur le président monsieur me
sépare en deux minutes que l'on peut
épuiser toute cette question c'est un
peu compliqué mais le cfl s'est passé fl
monsieur le ministre qui a décidé de
transférer des frais de gestion
départements et régions et donc
d'atténuer largement pour elles mêmes de
compenser plus que compensé pour elle la
baisse des dotations et de laisser
finalement les communes supporter le
gros de l'effort et c'est le cas en 2014
on aura l'occasion d'y revenir ensuite
quand vous dites renforcer
l'intercommunalité moi je je parle
d'intérêts l'intégration et d'une
mutualisation et les deux choses ne sont
pas identiques dont il faut bien faire
la part des choses souvent les confond
et moi je suis pour favoriser la
mutualisation l'intégration je le disais
tout à l'heure si ça crée des économies
d'échelle je ne vois pas pourquoi on
dépenserait de l'argent public
supplémentaires pour soutenir des
économies d'échelle et si il n'y a pas
d'économies d'échelle
on ne fait pas d'interdît conclure mais
j'ai encore du temps je suis pas encore
dans le temps additionnel monsieur le
président donc je disais que moi je suis
pour fonctionner au clonage
l'intégration voilà je remercie partie
comme ici m'a laissé un peu de temps
additionnel tout à l'heure et la parole
est maintenant à notre collègue philippe
dallier pour le groupe
les républicains avaient la parole pour
2010 monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues je crois
notre des balles démontre surtout les
bons chacun s'accorde à dire qu'il nous
faut une réforme de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement et une réforme des
mécanismes de péréquation est visible
inéquitable pour la dgf tout le monde en
est d'accord et des mécanismes de
péréquation qui sont aussi assez
particulier puisque une commune de
seine-saint-denis comme la mienne peut
être éligible à l'adsl est contributrice
aux pics
la question qui se pose est de savoir si
on peut mener une réforme comme celle là
dans un contexte budgétaire pour les
collectivités locales qui va être
extrêmement difficile
12 milliards et demi de baisse des
dotations pour les collectivités locales
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre je vous le redis c'est
extrêmement difficile à supporter et on
voit bien les premières conséquences la
chute de l'investissement des
collectivités locales en france 70% des
investissements publics ce sont les
collectivités locales
et donc des conséquences sur les
secteurs du bâtiment des travaux publics
certains vont jusqu'à dire que 0 6% de
croissance seraient perdus à cause de la
baisse de ses dotations
alors oui nous devons faire des
économies et contribuer au redressement
des comptes publics mais la question qui
se pose c'est à savoir à quel rythme
nous pouvons le faire et là monsieur le
ministre je crois que les décisions qui
sont prises aujourd'hui vont conduire
beaucoup de collectivités locales les
deux tiers des communes en 2010 est dans
une situation budgétaire extrêmement
difficile une étude du sénat l'a
démontré d'ici deux ans 66% des communes
n'auront plus les moyens d'autofinancer
leurs investissements et seront dans le
rouge alors qu'est ce qu'on va faire on
vend on va s'endetter alors que le bus
est de désendetter le pays
on va augmenter les impôts alors que le
but c'est effectivement de réduire la
pression fiscale faire des économies on
en rit cherchera mais nous n'en
trouveront pas à l'échelle de la baisse
des dotations
alors monsieur le ministre ma question
est la suivante oui à cette réforme de
la dgf elle est nécessaire et des
mécanismes de péréquation mais il nous
faut un moratoire ou un allongement de
la période pendant laquelle l'état va
effectivement diminuer les dotations en
direction des communes
êtes vous prêts à cela monsieur le
ministre mais un merci pour vous
répondre la parole à christian eckert
vous avez la parole monsieur le ministre
si monsieur le président et merci à vous
sur sénateurs puisque vous avez dit
quelque chose d'extrêmement important et
vous l'avez de répéter deux fois il sera
que nous pouvons nous réjouir
vous avez dit oui à une réforme de la
dgf je crois de la part de votre groupe
c'est une prise de position extrêmement
importante région enregistre comme un
point extrêmement positif parmi les
choses qui pourraient nous rassembler
vous avez ensuite mis l'accent sur
nombre de choses qui nous divisent je me
dirais je ne ferai qu'un seul calcul si
vous voulez doute coin table prenons
admettons les 12 milliards et demi de
baisse de notation que vous évoquez elle
porte sur une période de cinq ans
puisqu'il ya eu un moratoire à milliard
et demi puis ensuite 11 milliards sur
trois ans ce qui fait ce qui fait 5 ans
ce sénateur moratoire un milliard et
demi plus trois fois les 3,6 milliards
ça fait cinq ans c'est à dire une baisse
d'environ 6% des recettes réelles de
fonctionnement de l'ensemble des
collectivités locales puisque s'élève à
220 autour de 220 milliards si on
additionne ces 6 % sur cinq ans ce
sénateur fond dans un contexte c'est que
je dis pas que c'est facile je dis pas
accès aisé mais je crois que c'est un
effort significatif mais que cela peut
se gérer
mais la question du jour c'est surtout
est-il opportun de le faire à ce moment
je pense que oui pourquoi parce que dans
un contexte où le maître mot c'est
l'hétérogénéité c'est à dire avoir des
situations assez confortable il y en a
et avoir des situations plutôt tendue
faire demander le même effort à tous
fera qu effectivement il y en a qui sont
formulées comme ça qu'ils subissent la
double peine donc je pense qu'il faut
effectivement j'ai dit rebondir sur
cette difficulté collective pour
soutenir soutenir une réforme de la dgf
c'est ce que vous faites et le
gouvernement attend vos propositions
ceux d'alliés ce ministre pour ce qui
concerne la baisse c'est bien quatre ans
un milliard et demi l'an bébé dedans
l'an dernier et 3 6 milliards 2015 16 et
17 et savait déjà été gelés l'année
dernière je vous la corde monsieur
ministre mais la baisse
elle est bien sûr quatre ans je sais que
vous faites que ces comparaisons en
disant 6% finalement sur quatre ou cinq
exercices c'est pas grand chose mais
monsieur le ministre
pendant que nos recettes baissent les
dépenses
nous ne pouvons pas nous pouvons
ralentir leur hausse
mais il est extrêmement difficile
il de les réduire et vous le savez bien
60 % du budget des communes
essentiellement ce sont des frais de
personnel vous savez bien que les
communes ne maîtrise pas à
l'augmentation du point le gvt
les augmentations de charges que vous
votez ou que le parlement vote
régulièrement
et puis tout le reste augmente également
l'électricité le gaz les frais de
télécommunication donc nous avons un
effet de ciseaux monsieur le ministre
vous le savez donc ça se cumulent la
baisse des recettes d'un côté et la
poursuite de la hausse des dépenses même
à un rythme inférieur donc le sénat à
démontrer au travers de sonde dans son
étude que nous allions nous trouver une
conclusion très difficile il faut que
vous en teniez compte parce que sinon au
bout du compte ce sont les entreprises
qui vont trinquer
on nous annonce 30 mille chômeurs de
plus dans les bâtisses dans le bâtiment
cette année malheureusement nous ne
pourrons que le constater à fin 2015
merci la parole est au président jacques
mézard pour le gros du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci monsieur le président messieurs
les ministres une question pour chacun
dans notre assemblée qui représente
constitutionnellement les collectivités
locales et avant que vous ne les tout
fier par le non cumul nous sommes leurs
voix légitime alors ces collectivités et
nos concitoyens ont besoin de lisibilité
de simplification et d'équité pas
forcément d'égalité c'est impossible et
d'équité dans une approche globale de
leurs ressources tant au niveau des
dotations de l'état que de leurs
ressources fiscales
c'est devenu et vous l'avez dit monsieur
ministre incompréhensible et injuste le
premier terme étant la justification
trop souvent du second cette évolution
législative ne peut réussir il faut le
dire qu'en début de mandat présidentiel
car ce qu'ils vont percevoir moins et
payez plus vos murs les et ceux qui en
bénéficieront seront silencieux le
quinquennat et la snow éloigné d'un tel
objectif
le gouvernement a décidé d'une baisse
brutale d'ici 2017 12,5 milliards et un
nombre important et nous l'avons vu avec
notre collègue d'alliés dans le rapport
que nous avons fait un nombre important
de collectivités seront contraintes de
renoncer à tout investissement
et d'augmenter la fiscalité locale
quelles mesures comptez vous prendre
pour éviter le naufrage de ces
collectivités pas tout mais celles qui
sont le plus en difficulté et réaliser
une baisse perd et quattre hills avec
quel calendrier
seconde question simple confirmez vous
monsieur le ministre vallini les
conclusions du rapport que vous avez
commandé à la commissaire à l'égalité
des territoires je cite la dg devrait
être un outil d'accompagnement de la
décentralisation renforcée de la réforme
territoriale alors qu'ils ne pèsent
actuellement que pour un tiers du budget
du bloc communal le budget des oeufs pci
doit être renforcée pour atteindre les
deux tiers du poids total de ce bloc
dans cette logique la dgf pourrait être
déterminée exclusivement sur la base de
critères calculé à l'échelle des epc y
est versée uniquement à ces
établissements publics
est ce votre projet la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président mais hazard sur le premier
point la dgf et illizi vous l'avais dit
je devais dit aussi elle est injuste il
faut corriger ses effets qui renforce
les inégalités parfois entre
collectivités locales alors que ça
devrait être le contraire et le
gouvernement il travaille de son côté
en tenant bien bien sûr le plus grand
compte des travaux de la mission
parlementaire conduite par christine
pires bonnet jusqu'à ces dernières
semaines par le regretté sénateur jean
germain
le comité des finances locales sera
évidemment saisi et la haute assemblée
sera évidemment comme chambre
représentant les territoires la plus
concernée par ce débat quant au rapport
du cgiet je n'ai ni à le confirmer ni
l'infirmer il est sous la signature de
la directrice du cgiet de ses
collaborateurs c'est leur avis qui
n'engage que ceux qui ont rédigé ce
rapport le gouvernement je le répète ne
veux pas anticiper sur les conclusions
de la mission parlementaire et surtout
sur les travaux des deux chambres du
parlement sur les mesures que le
gouvernement compte prendre elles sont
nombreuses à existe déjà pour éviter à
certaines collectivités de renoncer à
tout investissement je réponds par
là-même aussi à monsieur d'allier vous
savez que le premier ministre a reçu
votre jours et nous étions là avec
christian eckert la mf que des mesures
nouvelles ont été annoncées en plus de
ce qui avait été annoncé au mois d'avril
en matière de remboursement de la tva de
prêt à taux zéro de la caisse des dépôts
pour anticiper le remboursement de
l'état en direction des collectivités
locales un fonds spécial
d'investissement pourraient être créés
d'un milliard d'euros pour aider les
communes les plus en difficulté de la
même façon que le prêt à taux zéro la
caisse des dépôts pourrait être
pérennisée sur deux années voilà des
propositions qui ont été faites à la mf
nous pensons revoir la mf enfin le
premier ministre a proposé aux prisons
baroin de les revoir au mois de juillet
il ya aussi l'aide aux maires bâtisseurs
de qui est doté de 100 millions d'euros
pour aider les communes dans les zones
les plus tendues à investir dans le dans
le logement il y à l'augmentation de la
detr qui a été voté en loi de finances
plus de 100 millions d'euros n'est pas
concluant à 800 millions d'euros bref
beaucoup de mesures qui montre que le
gouvernement est préoccupé par la
situation des collectivités locales et
les aident à continuer à investir
monsieur le président mais art merci
monsieur le ministre mais je constate
que n'ont pas de réponses précises sur
les conséquences de cette baisse de 12
milliards et demi vous nous dites le
premier ministre a annoncé un milliard
pour les collectivités les plus en
difficulté sur quels critères on a bien
vu la réaction de la mf
parce que vous allez cumulés moi je suis
pour la réforme de la dgf mais vous
allez cumulée à la fois la baisse 12
milliards et demi d'euros
une réforme de la dgf avec un calendrier
hypothétique et une répartition indue
d'une aide dont on connaît mal les
critères aux communes les plus en
difficulté or le rapport que nous avons
fait avec philippe dallier et charles
guené démontre qu'il ya une majorité de
communes qui vont être en difficulté
c'est pas avec un milliard d'euros que
vous allez solutionner le problème quant
au fait que vous n'impliquerait pas
forcément les conclusions du
commissariat légalité et
territoire permet quand même d'avoir
toujours un point d'interrogation parce
que jusqu'ici ce qu'on voit arriver dans
les textes c'est ce qu'il ya dedans
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à notre collègue al arich a pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain vous
avez la parole
si le président comme d'autres collègues
je voudrais dire que nous sommes
nombreux à être engagé dans la réflexion
pour cette réforme de la dgf et qu'il
n'y a pas débat sur la nécessité de la
réaliser compte tenu des diagnostics
qu'ont exprimé les deux ministres
simplement je voudrais appeler
l'attention en retenant bien ce qu'a dit
le ministre christian eckert tout à
l'heure sur la nécessité d'explorer
toutes les pistes sur la difficulté de
mener l'exercice dans le mois qui vient
car quand nous examinons les critères de
répartition qui pourrait remplacer la
multiplicité le cloisonnement des
différents critères actuels qui ont
tendance à se contredire
nous voyons bien que certains l'idée de
la notation universel trouve assez
facilement un accord entre nous que sur
la prise en compte de la ruralité voit
aussi que quelles pourraient être les
outils en revanche sur d'autres facteurs
et notamment sur les modalités de
resserrement des inégalités et sur la
question des charges de centralité
nous ne sommes pas du tout au bout du
travail
deuxièmement la réflexion sur ce qui
pourrait remplacer la dotation
d'intercommunalité actuel qui ça a été
très bien dit par un sens de leur ai
tout à l'heure et quand même le résultat
d'un mécanisme d'incitation qui n'a plus
d'objet les principes mêmes qui doivent
guider une nouvelle dotation
d'intercommunalité ne sont pas définies
ne sont pas clarifiées entre nous
troisième observation lorsqu'on inscrit
une réforme de la dgf surtout de cette
ampleur dans une loi de finances on se
crée à soi même les conditions de débats
les plus restrictives et en particulier
pour le sénat qui verra arriver ce sujet
avec bref des temps de débat à la fin
novembre
et donc je suis obligé de faire une
révélation grave devant le sénat
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 11 juin donc
est il raisonnable
de penser qu'on aura terminé d'ici la
présentation du projet de loi de
finances l'ensemble de ces débats nous
avons été quelques-uns à saisir le
compte de ce critère d'état christian
eckert des difficultés de boucler dans
un certains défauts coupure la révision
des bases il nous a entendus moi je
voudrais plaidé auprès du gouvernement
pour qu'on se donne un peu plus de temps
ces reculs de mesures d'évolution vers
la justice en 2016 mais que nous
gardions l'année 2016 pour finir
correctement cette réforme de la dgf
dans un climat financier qui sera
peut-être un peu éclairci est là pour
vous répondre la parole est à christian
eckert secrétaire d'état en charge du
budget monsieur le ministre
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs et sénatrices et sénateurs le
seul ministre à l'un des chats je crois
que le meilleur moyen de ne pas aboutir
à une réforme c'est de commencer par
penser qu'on n'aura pas le temps de
l'élaborer et différents gouvernements
au travers du temps sur ce sujet de la
dgf ou sur d'autres sujets comme celui
de la révision des valeurs locatives
ce sont effectivement retrouvé à se dire
c'est tellement lourd c'est pas le
moment n'aura pas le temps ce pas trop
donc moi je pense que et je sens quelque
chose qui bouge pardon de vous le dire
comme ça je suis pas là au dessus ou en
dessous je suis au milieu et il y a
quelques semaines ou quelques mois on
entendait beaucoup beaucoup de voix qui
disait pas question de revoir la dgf pas
question un peu comme certains qu'ils
soient assis sur leurs privilèges qui
disait parce que c'était souvent cela
qu'ils parlaient qui disait faisons
jouer tous les conservatismes
alors on trouve toujours une raison pour
dire c'est pas le moment en fin de
législature
c'est compliqué il faut attendre la
révision la fin de la révision des
valeurs locatives
on peut trouver plein de raisons
aujourd'hui je sens et je suis bien
entendu tout à l'heure le groupe l'est
républicain qui dit
qui disait oui nous sommes d'accord pour
nous engager dans cette réforme
alors faisons le résolument je crois que
nous avons les outils je répète que le
gouvernement est à la disposition avec
les moyens administratifs les légers au
les grands ordinateurs dont nous
disposons pour faire toutes les
simulations et parmi ces questions c'est
une question qu'il faudra évoquer
explorant la piste d'un mode de calcul
d'une dotation calculé j'ai pas dis
versé au niveau territorial
pourquoi parce qu'il ya des communes
riches dans des intercommunalités
pauvres qui se trouvent parfois moins
peu var donc les communes pauvres sont
prélevés par le fric
vous avez une situation symétrique et ce
n'est pas tenable donc il faut
travailler sur tous ces sujets avec
l'ambition de réussir et je pense qu'on
avec la volonté nous arrivons à tenir
des délais compatibles je l'espère avec
la loi de finances initiale de 2007
alain richard j'enregistre votre espoir
monsieur le ministre mais je voudrais
rebondir sur justement un exemple que
vous venez de donner le spica été mis en
place à l'échelle intercommunale et nous
avez été nombreux à mettre d'accord bon
ça fait maintenant trois ans qu'on
expérimente l'exercice et ses
difficultés de répartition interne aux
communautés aux intercommunalités sur
lequel nous avons été quelques-uns à
vous alerter depuis un moment n'ont pas
encore été surmontée
ça ça m'a plutôt dans mon sens en disant
écoutez il faut que dans la loi de
finances 2016 il y ait des mesures de
justice
on en convient mais si on se donnait
l'année 2016 on aurait d'une part la
possibilité d'un vrai débat
parlementaire les échanges qui viennent
d'avoir lieu montre qu'on peut se
rapprocher mais il faut que ça il faut
que cette réforme à long terme soit
vraiment partagé et j'ajouterais quand
même une autre observation c'est que
quand on sera en 2016
on verra la fin du prélèvement pour la
contribution exercice allée à l'équipe
des finances publiques et vous pourrez
aussi vous dire quel est le choix du
gouvernement quant au mode d'évolution
il faut qu'on vive allure de la dgf car
il n'est pas forcé qu'elle soit toujours
en baisse merci
la parole est à notre collègue michel
bouvard pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres
personne ne conteste le bien fondé d'une
réforme de la dgf cela a été dit regarde
sa complexité
personne ne contexte non plus le bien
fondé de la péréquation
ceci étant après que vincent de l'est
insisté sur les effets sur les
investissements après que notre collègue
alain richard et parler des communes qui
ont les charges de centralité de
ruralité permettez moi d'évoquer la
situation des communes touristiques qui
ne refuse pas la solidarité mais qui
entendent défendre la compétitivité du
tourisme français comme le souhaite
d'ailleurs laurent fabius à juste titre
ces communes sont pour la quasi-totalité
soumise à la double peine
une réfaction de la dgf qui n'était pas
prévu au moment où le flic a été mis en
place et la montée du spic inexorable
qui ampute dans certaines stations entre
2 et 3 millions les ressources et cela
va se poursuivre privant d'une capacité
d'investissement de 20 à 30 millions à
un moment où la compétition
internationale dans le secteur du
tourisme est de plus en plus vives
messieurs les ministres mes questions
sont simples la première comment peut-on
avoir une péréquation plus juste jolie
uniquement ce que disait la cour des
comptes dans son rapport de cette année
sur les finances locales
la péréquation ne s'est pas accompagnée
de l'adoption d'un cadre global
permettant d'en assurer la cohérence de
l'ensemble d'en évaluer l'efficacité
elle repose sur un ensemble de
dispositifs ajoutés les uns aux autres
par sédimentation et la cour appelle
dans ses observations et dans ceux
recommandations à procéder à des
évaluations de niveau de ressources et
de charges compéter de charge des
collectivités qui s'appuie sur des
logiques cohérente
entendez-vous au sein de la dgf recréer
une dotation spécifique des communes
touristiques comme elle existait avant
95 avec ses propres mécanique perec
watry ce qui incitait à l'investissement
plutôt que de privilégier l'effet de
rendre dont bénéficiait un certain
nombre de collectivités pour vous
répondre la parole et christian est
clair vous avez la parole monsieur min
sûr présents messieurs sénatrices et
sénateurs le sénateur michel bouvard
vous et vous quel à un sujet qui vous
est familier sur lequel bien sûr vous
connaissez et vous reconnaissez que les
communes touristiques bénéficie déjà
d'un saut nombre de dispositions pour
tenir compte de la spécificité qu'elles
peuvent représenter ainsi d'un point
très important dans le nombre
d'habitants pris en compte pour le
calcul de la dgf les résidences
secondaires sont prises en compte
à la différence d'un raison d'un
habitant je crois par résidence
secondaire ce qui permet dans les
répartitions d'ivoire un avantage
certain j'évoque rapidement la
possibilité d'instituer la taxe de
séjour ainsi qu'un certain nombre
d'autres dispositions sur le classement
de station classée de tourisme qui
permettent là aussi d'accéder à des
majorations de notation alors
faudra-t-il puisque c'est votre question
à avoir dotation spécifique pour les
communes touristiques le parlement
décidera nous demander aujourd'hui la
position du gouvernement
vraiment reste prudent vous dire
pourquoi parce que si l'on veut créer
des dotations pour l'ensemble des
communes qui ont un caractère spécifique
je crois que nous allons multiplier les
dotations des communes de montagne qui
sont pas forcément touristiques font
également demandé des discussions
particulières je pense à nos collègues
d'outre-mer nous avons souvent un débat
avec le sénateur patients sur la
question de la dotation proportionnel à
la surface et son plafonnement
enfin communes inondables
enfin vous
vous aurez nous aurons bien sûr une
inventive de créativité qui sous je
crois de nous faire échapper à l'une des
l'un des objectifs qui est un objectif
de lisibilité et de simplification voilà
mais le parlement il travaillera et je
crois que bien sûr il aura à se
prononcer sur ces questions tout à fait
légitimes
merci monsieur lui disent tu sues
bouvard quelques secondes
ce ministre merci de votre réponse on ne
peut pas dire que le nombre de
résidences secondaires soient
représentatifs partout délit de même que
le produit de la taxe de séjour couvre
parfois à peine les investissements
qu'il faut faire en matière de sécurité
dans une station pour autant ce que je
rappelais c'est qu'une une station
touristique c'est une commune plus une
entreprise que ces stations sont
soumises aujourd'hui une concurrence
internationale singulièrement dans les
secteurs de montagne qui est très vive
avec l'autriche avec l'italie avec la
suisse à ce que dans ces pays
les communes ne sont pas forcément
autorités organisatrices en matière de
gestion des domaines touristique
c'est ce qui fait la différence avec la
france je pense que ceci mérite d'être
prise en compte si nous voulons que le
tourisme continue à apporter son écot en
termes de création d'emplois et surtout
en terme de redressement des finances
publiques
si vos chers collègues la parole et à
notre collègue vincent eblé pour le
groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président messieurs les ministres chers
collègues l'avancée des travaux du
comité des finances locales nous a
permis de comprendre qu'il était
envisagé de distinguer la réforme de la
dgf du bloc communal de celle des autres
collectivités
nous partageons ici sur tous les bancs
la nécessité de faire cesser les
inégalités qui perdurent au détriment
des communes modeste mais il convient
également de se préoccuper de la
situation des départements
celles ci illustrent bien le
vieillissement des mécanismes actuels de
la dgf qui a cristallisé les situation
héritée de l'histoire sans prendre en
compte le développement et la dynamique
des territoires
si l'amplitude des cars de la dgf versée
au département est inférieure à celle
des communes cet écart n'en est pas
moins extrêmement préjudiciable au bon
fonctionnement
compétences contraintes qu'exercent les
conseils départementaux en particulier
dans le champ des solidarités permettez
moi de prendre l'exemple de mon
département dont la dgf est anormalement
faible en 2014 alors que le potentiel
financier de la seine et marne est
inférieure au potentiel financier moyen
des départements la seine et marne a
reçu une dgf par habitant de 113 euros
alors qu'elle est de 150 2 pour les
hauts-de-seine qui dispose pourtant d'un
potentiel financier infiniment supérieur
comment cela est-il possible
ce très faible niveau de dgf en seine et
marne trouve son origine dans les
ajustements historique des mécanismes de
répartition de la dgf qui sont venus
cristalliser des situations existantes
l'intégration en son sein de dotation et
de compensation auparavant indépendante
a figé les écarts de richesse
ainsi les départements sont aujourd'hui
financées par ces dotations selon des
situations non actualisées qui date par
exemple de 1999 swahili à seize années
date de la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle par la disparition de la
part salaires
c'est donc la dynamique économique des
mauves à votre question car j'y suis qui
n'est pas prise en compte et qui est
pénalisé c'est extrêmement préjudiciable
sur le plan économique sur celui la
croissance au plan de la mobilisation
des territoires qui ne sont plus
intéressés à leur propre développement
je vous remercie de me dire si vous
partagez cette analyse nous réclamons
une réforme des mécanismes de
répartition de la dgf des départements
sur le même calendrier que celui des
autres échelons territoriaux
j'aimerais connaître également sur ce
dernier point votre avis pour vous
répondre
du moins de deux minutes le andré
vallini merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur et blé c'est vrai
que nous pensons qu'il faut commencer
par le bloc communal en matière de
réforme de la légère parce que c'est
d'abord la partie la plus importante de
la dgf 22 milliards 1,9 sur 36 milliards
60 % et c'est aussi parce que les c'est
là que les injustices les inégalités
sont les plus fortes
c'est donc avec la corde des
départements de france de l'adf que nous
pensons reporter la réforme de la dgf
départementale au 1er janvier 2018 pour
autant monsieur le sénateur le
gouvernement est très conscient des
problématiques que vous avez exposé
notamment
celle de la seine et marne en la
comparant cette problématique à celle
des hauts-de-seine département très
favorisés par rapport à la
seine-et-marne qui est défavorisée par
les mécanismes actuels de la dgf
si nous n'avons pas prévu de réformer
tout de suite à des jeunes des
départements nous avons pris des mesures
vous en souvenez dès juillet 2013 ce
qu'on appelait les accords de matignon
passe de 1936 ceux de 2013 qui
concernaient notamment la compensation
des trois allocations individuelles de
solidarité est comprise ente conseil
général à l'époque je m'en étais sans
doute comme vous réjouit en 2015 en
outre et comme pour les communes a déjà
des départements a été simplifiée par
l'agrégation de la dotation de base et
du complément de garantie et elle
continue à tenir compte des évolutions
de la population
la péréquation verticale continue quant
à elle de progresser + 20 millions
d'euros pour les départements soit + 4 %
pour atteindre 1 milliards 443 euros en
idem pour la péréquation dit horizontal
et des partants les plus pauvres
bénéficient de l'augmentation de 30
millions d'euros des ressources du fonds
national de péréquation de la cvae des
départements portant son volume total à
86 millions si vous pouvez conclure oui
monsieur le président oui que le
gouvernement est très conscient des pros
les départements mais nous pensons
néanmoins qu'il faut commencer par la
dgf communal tout en aidant les
départements quelques mots notre
collègue et blé pour permettre jeu juste
pour réagir à la mention qui est faite
d'une position de l'adf
dans cette affaire nous travaillons à
somme nulle ceux qui gagnent le fond
détriment de ceux qui vont perdre donc
évidemment il ya 50% des collectivités
concernées qui sont contre la réforme
mais nous parlons de péréquation nous
faisons exactement l'inversé l'état
donne plus aux riches qu'aux pauvres
il est urgent de conduire cette réforme
mon cher collègue
je souhaite informer le sénat que la
commission mixte paritaire chargée de
proposer un texte sur les dispositions
restant en discussion du projet de loi
modifiant la loi du 2 juillet 2014
relatives à l'octroi de mer est parvenu
à douala pour ces questions cribles
thématiques consacrées à la réforme de
la dotation globale de fonctionnement
vous avez pu l'entendre dans l'ensemble
les parlementaires on parlait d'une voix
unie cela quelle que soit leur groupe
politique pour dénoncer le contexte très
difficile dans lequel s'inscrit cette
réforme ce contexte c'est celui d'une
baisse des dotations de l'état aux
collectivités
la sénatrice communiste marie france
beaufils a ainsi parlé et je la cite du
lourd tribut payé par les collectivités
pour répondre dogme de bruxelles elle a
aussi réclamé que les écarts injustifiés
entre les collectivités soient
compensées à l'occasion de cette réforme
c'est le secrétaire d'état andré vallini
qui lui a répondu tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle a répondu affirmativement il
a appelé à une dotation globale de
fonctionnement plus juste plus lisible
il a également rappelé que lors du
dernier projet de loi de finances il y
avait déjà eu des efforts effectués en
la matière dames en matière de
péréquation
notons également que les sénateurs se
sont exprimés sur les différents
échelons un des collectivités région
département mais aussi et surtout
commune
c'était l'objet de l'interpellation du
centriste vincent delahaye qui voient
dans cette réforme une future
disparition des communes orchestrée par
le gouvernement c'est christian écart
tient alors répondu il a rétorqué que la
répartition des efforts dans la
diminution des dotations n'avait pas été
décidée par le seul gouvernement mais
également par le comité des finances
locales
enfin on peut également noter
l'intervention de philippe dallier
sénateur les républicains mer des
pavillons sous bois en seine saint denis
une intervention remarquée très
applaudie puisque l'élu a brandi le
spectre d'une baisse de l'investissement
public très dommageable à la croissance
avec cette baisse des dotations vous
pouvez toujours voir et revoir toutes
les séances sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr
à 16 heures et demain vous pourrez voir
affaire à suivre sur le business des
férias anime un reportage de nora ahmadi
quant à moi je vous retrouve à dix
8h pour la suite des travaux du sénat et
l'audition de jean claude ameisen
président du conseil consultatif
national d'éthique très bonne journée
sur les chaînes parlementaires